The wound has healed. By
any chance, you all know my sister.
Hey, my name is Alpha Nagase, and my sister,
Milfa Nagase, took care of me.
Actually, I haven't talked to her about
our country.  I broke up with her to wrap my arms around her as soon as she escaped. She's doing
well. I
can't believe she's injured and missing. Maybe you or she is the
better one. Why?
These two are also younger sisters, and I think they're
nice and honest men, fun to be around, and
reliable.They're
also both intelligent and honest men who
look like they'll grow up to be good men as they get older.
He seems fun and dependable.I said that I
hate men who are arrogant, selfish men, and men who don't seem to get angry even though they're old.Would you like to
come and live with your sister?
That's no good.As you may know,
I have the power to heal.My sister has great wisdom and
talent.That's
why we were targeted.If the two of us came together in an instant, we would be able to meet
each other.  The balance is likely to collapse and trouble will occur,
but I won't run away again. I'll be
fine. I'll try not to let that happen.
Anyway, I'm going to visit our country once. Ta-chan is my
precious helper. Even though he's the
prince of prison, I can't give him away.
If you want to go home with Zen, you have to defeat us and then go. Even if only Ze gives in, that's all you'll
know. But I have
n't changed my socks, but I haven't changed my pants either. But,
thank you very much. Please say hello to my sister.
Hey, let's go home.  Let's get in the way
[Music]